مع تجدد الاشتباكات دول تجلي دبلوماسييها
من الخرطوم
وثيقه تكشف قدره الصين على تعطيل الاقمار
الاصطناعيه
والملاريا يتغلب على اللقاحات في افريقيا
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من قناه
العربيه فاهلا بكم
[موسيقى]
نبدا من السودان فبعد ساعات من الهدوء
النسبي في معظم مناطق الاشتباكات تجدد
القتال بين قوات الدعم السريع والجيش
السوداني في ام درمان ومحيط القياده
العامه للقوات المسلحه في الخرطوم وبينما
تسعى دول عده لاجلاء مواطنها اعلنت واشنطن
اكتمال الاجلاء موظفي سفاراتها في الخرطوم
وعائلاتهم بدوره اعلن رئيس الوزراء
البريطاني ريشيسوناك ان القوات المسلحه
لبلادها اتمت عمليه اجراء معقده وسريعه
لدبلوماسيين البريطانيين وعائلاتهم كما
تعمل دول غربيه اخرى كاطاليا وفرنسا على
تامين اجلاء مواطنيها ودبلوماسيينها من
السودان في اقرب وقت ممكن
فضائح الوثائق الامريكيه المسربه لا تزال
مستمره اخرها كشف احدى الوثائق عن معرفه
امريكيه بقدره الصين الكبيره في معركه
الفضاء صحيفه نيويورك تايمز كشفت عن محتوى
الوثيقه التي تخص وكاله الاستخبارات
المركزيه الامريكيه وجاء فيها ان الصين
قادره على استغلال او اختطاف الاقمار
الاصطناعيه للعدو احد تلك الاسلحه الصينيه
هو نظام تشويش مفصل لارباك الاقمار
الاصطناعيه وتحييدها عن طريق محاكاه
الاشارات التي تتلقاها من مشغلي المحطه
الارضيه والتسبب في حدوث خلل وهو ما قد
يمكن الصين من السيطره على القمر
الاصطناعي
رغم تطوير لقاحات فعاله ضده لا يزال
الملاريا يشكل كابوسا مرعبا لقاره افريقيا
والسبب بحسب منظمه الصحه العالميه هو قدره
المرض على تطوير نفسه لمقاومه الادويه
والتطعيمات الصحه العالميه قدرت اعداد
المصابين في العالم بنحو ربع مليون شخص
وتسجل الغالبيه العظمى من الحالات
والوفيات في افريقيا بنسبه 96% كما تتركز
اكثر من نصف وفيات الملاريا المسجله
بالعالم في دول افريقيه على راسها نيجيريا
بنسبه 31% والكونغو بنسبه تزيد عن 12% من
الحلب فيما دفع هذا الوضع الكارثي بمنظمه
الصحه العالميه الى اطلاق استراتيجيه
للتصدي لهذا الخطر في افريقيا
في فرنسا وردا على اصرار ماكرون على المضي
قدما بقانون التقاعد الجديد هددتني نقابه
عمال الطاقه الفرنسيه بقطع الكهرباء عن
مهرجان كان السينمائي في نسخته السابعه
والستين المقرره في مايو المقبل النقابه
هددت ايضا بقطع الكهرباء عن مزيد من
الاحداث الدوليه الكبرى التي ستقام في
البلاد كجائزه موناكو والكبرى للفورميولا
1 ودوره رولون جاروس للتنس ومهرجان
افينيون مسرحي قناه قالت ان ممثلين نقابه
الطاقه لديهم الوسائل التقنيه الكافيه
لقطع الكهرباء خلال المهرجانات والمناسبات
الكبرى وسبق وان فعلوها في عده مناسبه
كقطع الكهرباء خلال زياره ماكرون لاحدى
الكليات في جنوب فرنسا
بعد ان حذف ايلون ماسك شارك التوثيق
الزرقاء من حسابات الاف المشاهير وكثير من
مستخدمي تويتر وضع نفسه في موقف لا يحسد
عليه عندما تعهد بالدفع عنهم مقابل خدمه
تويتر بلو وعلامه التوثيق الفنان المصري
محمد هنيدي الذي يصل عدد متابعيه على
تويتر لنحو 14 مليون متابع رد على ماسك
بتغريده قائلا انه قام بالواجب ودفع عنه
المبلغ هنيدي الذي رفض الدفع مقابل الخدمه
في وقت سابق اضاف قائلا تبين عوده اشتراكي
في خدمه تويتر بلو مع انني لم اشترك لكن
واضح انه ايلون ماسك حب يعمل معانا الواجب
ودفع الاشتراك الخدمه